[Music]
this is the story of an opportunity
offered to the daughters of the navajo
cherokee choctaw seneca to the pueblo
peoples the sioux winnebago apache to
all the indian peoples
[Music]
the story of an unusual school
[Music]
each year 80 young indian girls enroll
in the practical nurse school in
albuquerque
they come to build a career for
themselves
and to learn to serve the cause of
health among their people
they come from many tribes in many parts
of the country from oklahoma lita
when they told me at haskell institute
about the practical nursing school i
really wanted to go
my parents were so pleased
[Music]
i am smiling here in this picture taken
at the school but i was a little
fighting i think when packing to come
from new mexico elsie curley
our high school guidance teacher told us
about the school
harriet saint claire's mother is the
practical nurse
royce bohannon had two sisters at the
practical nurse school before her
three cousins came together from laguna
tell them david isabelle gays dear
violet softly
laverna kuka of arizona had always
wanted to be a nurse
and so had rose gomez of taos i saw the
good care the nurses gave in the
hospital it made me want to help people
that way too
especially the children
nancy calhoun came from minnesota
laverna highhawk and georgia ann eagle
came from south dakota
janice armstrong came the greatest
distance all the way from new york state
[Music]
classes begin at the school in august
and february each year many students are
brought by their family others come by
train joe herron meets them with the
school car
on arrival leader mei gumbai and harriet
sinclair stopped to look at the school
sign
they didn't quite know what to expect
the first day was a busy one
there were roommates to get acquainted
with lita may meets hers cecilia mirabal
from towels
it was unpacking to do
getting settled
receiving uniforms
trying them on for the first time
they were the teachers to meet
the school to see
[Music]
and that night a letter to write home
dear mother
our school being next door to the indian
boarding school there isn't time to be
homesick
it is a big and friendly campus
a church is just across the street
we have a cat here named professor
there is a great deal to learn
to do
to think about and understand
anatomy
the organs of the body
and the bones of the body the patient's
skeleton here surrounded is oscar gerard
albuquerque a favorite of the girls
the words are difficult as miss mirabal
discovers
students learn how to make hospital beds
how to read a thermometer and take
temperatures
pulse and respiration
they learn about diets
and how to serve food to bed patients
how to take blood pressures
the combined class and demonstration
room let some students watch
while others practice
sometimes on each other as here with
leda may learning how to get a patient
out of bed
and into a
wheelchair sometimes they practice with
dolls they call them mr and mrs chase
for the manufacturer who makes them
students also go to the albuquerque
sanatorium for a first look at what is
ahead
here their pink uniforms are covered
with a protective hospital gown and they
wear masks over nose and mouth
time now to use what they have learned
for real people really ill
to feel needed and appreciated
back in classes at the school questions
are sometimes easy and everyone knows
the answers
[Music]
sometimes not so easy and no one knows
but there are teachers
and books to help it isn't all work of
course the chuck wagon is a popular
interruption to classes
twice a day everyone flocks outside
there's plenty of time for play picnics
and cookouts hot dogs
and watermelon
regular meals are taken across the
campus in the big cafeteria for the
boarding school students
sports are popular after class strenuous
tennis
less strenuous croquet
archery is a favorite naturally
oh
bullseye twice there's time for dancing
with each other on the school porch
and for dancing with their dates perhaps
from the boarding school
[Music]
teas and parties are learning time as
well as fun how to set the table how to
serve
and to meet guests
here one of the doctors is a guest
cards are played some free evenings
and music others
television in the upstairs living room
is a favorite
and getting to know each other is
probably best of all
exchanging confidences showing pictures
in each other's rooms at night getting
to know all about each
other some of us who are city girls had
never seen a reservation elsie curley
showed me what a hogan is like
now i am anxious to visit one
i showed some of our now whole paintings
too
they like them
they're beautiful oh pretty pretty
this is the way my people paint
apache art shows much action
the hopies are the ones who make katrina
doll
see this is a mud head one of our clowns
do you like the party we make in a
problem
my grandmother maria made this
other arts are exhibited also miss curly
shows how to make fry bread
and boyfriends and dates are discussed
when they chatter and giggle and have a
fine time
they become fast friends
on saturdays they go shopping
and to church on sundays
letters home now are full of news
albuquerque is a busy city for the busy
streets but it has quiet places too
the state university is here
at sundown sandia mountains to the east
turn as pink as our uniform
historic santa fe is nearby
the girls have opportunities to visit
graduate practical nurses serve at the
indian hospital at santa fe many of the
most famous southwestern pueblos are
only a few hours from albuquerque taos
sanil de fonso home of the famous black
pottery
old santa anna
zuni noted for its silversmiths
and its waffle gardens
old acoma in the sky
variety
many of these are home to some of the
students and they delight in showing
them to their friends who come from far
away
this is fabulous country truly the land
of the seven cities of sybilla the
ancient civilizations
and the wonders of nature
[Music]
gallup where the intertribal ceremonials
are held each july is only half a day
away
so many things to see
but after the weekend sightseeing and
fun
back to books and classrooms for
examinations will be coming soon
names and grades are posted and the
girls crowd around to look for their
marks
at the end of four months the successful
students receive their caps probation is
over
now indeed there is news to write home
for leida may nona marie rose gomez and
the others
will leave the school for a while to go
out for clinical and public health
experience working under supervision of
registered nurses in the indian health
program
some will go to the albuquerque
sanatorium
already familiar
others the majority will go to the
navajo reservation
here they will serve for seven months at
the navajo medical center
they will live in the nurses home
they have their own counselor
and teacher
but here also they go to school but
there's a difference
they study now the care and problems
affecting actual individual patients
the longer practice this is real
each has certain patients of her own to
care for
the elderly
the newborn
a favorite assignment
mother and baby together
the restless youngsters and pediatrics
small
problems sometimes present themselves
the first time i was to give bed bath my
patient hid under her bed
but after i coaxed her out she didn't
mind her bath at all
the student nurses learn here to give
tender considerate care
they keep charts for their patients as
the registered nurses do they prepare
formulas
they confer with the dietitian
they help in preparing for surgery
rose gomez here is making up a surgical
bed
they get the supplies necessary for the
operations
they observe in the operating room
amphitheater during surgery sometimes
they assist at the scrub table
the crowded waiting room on clinic days
keeps them busy as they assist doctors
and nurses acting as interpreters
sometimes when there is a language
difficulty taking the patient's history
explaining about medicines and doctors
directions
practical nurse students also learn to
assist the public health nurses making
home visits on the navajo reservation
they assist in treating patients
in demonstrating proper baby care
they show how to bathe the baby with oil
instead of the precious water so scarce
on the reservation
in visits to these widely scattered
hogans on the vast reservation which
little miss gumbai could not even
imagine short months ago
the practical nurse student comes to
know its people
its summer aspect
its winter face
[Music]
students also assist public health
nurses in indian health clinics at the
pueblos
here laverna highhawk aids public health
nurse tui at santa ana
talking with patient joe garcia
she confers with the mothers
and helps weigh the baby
student days are full they go fast
four months of class work seven months
practical experience
now nearly time for graduation the girls
go back to the albuquerque school for a
final review of studies
teachers make their final reports and
evaluations consideration for each
girl's record
there are state board examinations to
take to secure their license to practice
there are happy jokes
graduation invitations to send proudly
home to parents
graduation uniforms to admire
and finally
the great day
graduation day we are different today
when i came i wouldn't have thought
anything could be finer than our pink
uniforms but all the whites the whites
symbolic of all they have been waiting
and working for
families gather from near and far
grandmother maria
the chief nurse officer of the united
states public health service arrives to
address the girls
the chief nurse of the indian health
service is there from washington
the doctors come also to wish them well
outside the auditorium the crowd grows
mothers and fathers brothers and sisters
from dakota colorado arizona oklahoma
minnesota
inside the indian school band tunes up
and suddenly it is time
in double line they march across the
familiar campus to the auditorium where
the exercises will be held
[Music]
the chief nurse officer tells them
i pray for each of you the reward of
deep satisfaction which comes only to a
nurse
the satisfaction of a child healed a
troubled spirit comforted
a death rate lord
a new way of health succeeding
and as they listen
they're thinking big thoughts
this is an important day
i am excited about it and what is coming
i wonder who my first patient will be
it didn't seem possible that today would
ever come my
i i feel so proud i know my mother is
too
miss kuka rises to give the class
response
[Music]
during our year at the indian school of
practical nursing we have had the
opportunity to learn our chosen
profession for many of us it has been a
lifelong desire for we know that as a
licensed practical nurse we can serve
our indian people and assist in
improving their health
there are certificates
and pins
and congratulations
and then they are graduates and tomorrow
is ahead
they are eligible to serve as graduate
licensed practical nurses in any state
in the union and in any hospital
many will serve by choice in indian
hospitals or field assignments
throughout the west to help add health
and knowledge of the gentle art of
healing to the other arts and treasures
of their people
but even as these graduates leave a new
class is coming in
would you like to join them
this is your invitation
you